good afternoon let me welcome you to the
army-navy Club
my name is harvey russia cough i'm the
chair of the committee standing
committee on law and national security
but as you know we just are trustees for
that particular entity because Holly
McMahon is truly the person who is
always the force behind this our
committee
these anniversary in 2012 coming up and
we have broken into a new sort of events
of holding luncheons and I want to thank
general Hemingway as always for being
such a gracious host at the army/navy
Club and we have a number of events
coming up but I just want to do some
business as we do when our committee is
together we have the 20th annual review
of the field of national security law
conference on November 4th and 5th which
will be held in Washington our opening
panel will be General Counsel's from the
key national security agencies and other
panels to address issues of legal
doctrine and particularly in
cybersecurity governance of the domestic
intelligence world national security
environmental change targeted killing
and use of unmanned aerial systems
national security transformation and at
the ethical challenges for national
security lawyers which judge Baker will
be involved as one of the major
panelists will also the keynote remarks
by dr. John Hamre from sei CSIS Senator
Lindsey Graham is will be also attending
as one of our speakers and we have an
invitation that we have extended today
and a priest to talk about the issue of
First Amendment and the national
security we also will have our
traditional breakfast coming up November
18th and that that will be having hey
sparks who's the senior associate deputy
general counsel for international
affairs and he will be discussing we
hope the pending publication of the
famous manual on the law of war but
we're really here today to listen to
Dick Clark and we have a series of books
that Dick Clark is written as he pointed
out I think he's within five books in
the last number of a couple of years
both fiction which I very very highly
recommend to you it was just great
reading and nonfiction but the book
issue is something that we have on our
committee has been committed to we have
Stewart Baker here who's just done
skating on stilts which is a wonderful
text that summarizes part of his public
and private career at the HS
we have Susan Ginsberg whose book on
borders and the concept of securing
human mobility and we also have Joe
Whitley and Lynn's espen whose book on
Homeland Security is something that our
committee has been very supportive of
over the years in a way Dick's book
which I will hold up for you is cyber
war the next threat to national security
I want to do about it which is also
co-authored with Robert Janaki and
Robert has also been something on the
Council on Foreign Relations Internet
Governance in the age of cyber security
that's also on the council's website and
is now curtilage this recently joined
the Department of Homeland Security so
as you can see our committee has been
dedicated to making public and bringing
the perspective of the legal community
to these pressing issues that we have
facing us in a 21st century Nick Clark
is quite literally an internationally
recognized expert on security homeland
security national security cyber
security and counterterrorism he is that
hard to open up the turn on your
television and ABC news and Nazi dick
giving very thoughtful commentary he
also attends a small school in Cambridge
where I used to teach at the Harvard
Kennedy School of Government dick has
served the last three presidents as a
senior White House adviser and over the
course of an unprecedented
11 consecutive years of White House
service he sailed numerous titles
including special assistant to president
for global affairs national coordinator
for security and counterterrorism
specialized ER to the president for
cybersecurity
he has had an extinguished a very
distinguished career prior to those
particular positions at the Pentagon
intelligence community State Department
he has served during the Reagan
administration was Deputy Assistant
Secretary of State for intelligence
during Bush 41 he was Assistant
Secretary of State for political
military affairs he's currently in the
private sector and he's a partner in
good harbor consulting and he advises
clients on a range of issues but I would
say the first time I actually met Dick
Clark was during the
Clinton administration when I was the
Department of Justice and FBI and Vic
was at the National Security Council and
as you know the department dresses FBI
are sort of hard organizations to crack
and there was an amount of respect for
dick and the service that he had
performed at the National City Council
of trying to focus the United States
government on these critical terrorism
issues and the emergence of cyber issues
he was at it he's been at it for a very
very long time
and regardless about how one feels about
dick and the issues that surround dick I
think it's very it's fair to say this is
someone who is devoted the substantial
part of his professional life to public
service and has always labored in a
manner in which he thought he was doing
the best things he could to ensure the
stability and of the Republic and the
security of Republic and I think I'd
like to have a warm set of applause for
dick and we thank him for his attendance
tonight today and I look forward to his
talk on summarizing the issue of cyber
war
well thanks very much
I thought I had stopped going to
meetings on targeted killing but glad to
know that there is still such things
well as you know a week from tomorrow is
Stephen Colbert's rally to keep fear
alive a few blocks from here so as a
warm-up to that I thought I would talk
to you about cyber war it's actually
three different phenomenon here and the
risk of being a little bit pedantic I
think it would it helps a lot at the
outset to define terms the three
phenomenon are cyber crime cyber
espionage and cyber war and they are
obviously related but distinct and they
all are problems we haven't solved in
fact problems we haven't come close to
solving two weeks ago the FBI announced
arrests of 20 people simultaneously here
in the United States and in the United
Kingdom who were cybercrime mules what
does that mean they were largely Russian
students here in the United States who
had been asked by organized criminals
back in Russia to open bank accounts and
large amounts of money would drop into
those bank accounts and their only
obligation was then to transfer that
money out of their bank accounts in the
United States to offshore bank accounts
now they were all arrested the people
who actually did the cyber crime that
generated the money to go into those
bank accounts we're not and they almost
never are cyber crime is now a
multi-billion dollar enterprise the
income coming in from cybercrime
parallels and and will soon probably
eclipse the amount of money that comes
in from the narcotics
cartel's billions of dollars now for the
most part that cyber crime is crime
against banks credit card companies and
when you're affected by it for the most
part your bank or your credit card
company will make you whole so we don't
have a big outcry in this country about
cybercrime because for the most part
although identity theft can be
time-consuming for you as an individual
to fix for the most part it doesn't cost
you money or at least you don't think it
does it costs you money if you're a
stockholder in a bank
it costs you money if you look at your
banking fees because the banks are
passing on the cost of cybercrime but
for the most part this sophisticated
cyber crime which by the way is now
getting so sophisticated that the cyber
criminals are hiring engineers and
hackers so that they can go in to source
code and computer chips of things that
are being manufactured so that when
those things are then sold the cyber
criminals will be able to get back in so
when you buy a computer now there is
some risk you buy a router or a server
there is some risk that cyber criminals
have already put a backdoor in but these
cyber criminals tend not to be in the
United States only the Mules are they
tend not to be in the United Kingdom
they tend to be in places like Belarus
Moldova Russia and other places and when
the FBI does its investigation gets its
court order so it can look into the
server traces the hack back to some
server in Moscow or Minsk they then
asked the State Department to issue
letters rogatory so that we can get a
little cooperation from the law
enforcement officials in those countries
and guess what happened nothing
nothing happens we have in effect
cybercrime sanctuary countries now why
would nice people like the Russians and
others create cyber sanctuaries cynical
people would think that law enforcement
and other government officials in those
countries are on the take and are
getting part of the billions of dollars
from the cybercrime activities even more
cynical people would point out that from
time to time those government's might
ask the cyber criminals who they know to
do them little favors I'm reminded of
the the scene in the first Godfather
moving on Marlon Brando grants some
favor to some critter supplicant who
says to the supplicant someday I will
ask you for a favor well I think that
happens with cybercrime you're allowed
to do your cybercrime from Russia or
Belarus Ukraine as long as you don't
attack in on our country long as you
don't attack in Russia and then when the
Russian government wants to do a cyber
war against Estonia as it did in 2007 or
a cyber war against the nation of
Georgia as it did in 2008 well you know
those attacks on the infrastructure in
Georgia and Estonia that crippled the
banking system crippled the
telecommunications system they weren't
done by the government of Russia
no no the Russian government says they
were done by patriotic activists who the
Russian government of course didn't
prosecute so it's convenient for some of
these governments to have these people
around to do their little dirty work for
them in cyberspace we've had problems
similar to this before where there were
countries that were not living up to
international standards we dealt with it
one that comes to mind is money
laundering
we had sanctuaries for money laundering
from narcotics from terrorism and
nations got together and created the
financial action task force and they
established model laws and they said you
need to pass those model laws and then
you need to enforce those model laws and
when islands in the Pacific and islands
and the Caribbean didn't they were then
told if you don't pass those model laws
and enforce those model laws if you
continue to be money along laundering
sanctuaries the United States and the
United Kingdom and Germany and France
Japan will no longer convert your
currency I had the pleasure of calling
the Prime Minister one of those little
Caribbean countries and delivering that
message was fun took about two weeks to
get the Parliament into session and
passed the model law we could be doing
things like this with regard to cyber
crime sanctuaries but we're not we could
have sanctions against countries that
refuse to cooperate in prosecution of
cybercrime we could limit their access
to the rest of cyberspace we could scan
all of the message traffic leaving their
countries we could have an international
system to do that they could pay a price
but right now we're paying the price
because the government has been unable
to get its mind around the problem a
cyber crime and thinks it's something
that we need to send assistant US
Attorney's off to worry about in 90
different jurisdictions send FBI agents
in to companies and put crime-scene tape
around their computers that's the way
we're addressing it now and we're
obviously not seriously addressing it
related to cybercrime cyber espionage
because some of the same people who are
doing cybercrime are doing cyber
espionage but there are others doing it
as well so what is cyber espionage well
primarily it's espionage the second
oldest profession in the world and cyber
espionage is importantly different from
regular espionage in old espionage if
you imagine you were the KGB station
chief the resident on Massachusetts
Avenue everything and you have the job
of recruiting somebody in the CIA and
somebody in the FBI to be a Russian spy
Soviet spy that was a that was a really
hard thing to do I mean if you picked
the wrong FBI agent to recruit he the
restroom if you pick the wrong CIA agent
to recruit it turned you in but yet they
succeeded in in getting Robert Hansen in
the FBI and Aldrich Ames at CIA and
others and those people for money or
traitors to their country and took
documents pieces of paper in their suit
jackets in their briefcases out of CIA
headquarters out of FBI headquarters
they went to little parks and Fairfax
County and dug holes and put the paper
in the ground dead letter drops and then
then the KGB guy from the embassy would
come by and dig it up and eventually
little pieces of paper would get into
Moscow where they'd be analyzed now
there was a lot of risk and a lot of
work for very little reward
well cyber espionage is different
because there's very little risk you sit
back in Moscow or Beijing or wherever
and instead of having your agent break
into a file cabinet
you have your hacker break into a server
and you don't get a few pieces of paper
you get petabytes terabytes of
information
I see looks of confusion about those
words on some faces so let's let's
say you get libraries of Congress worth
of pieces of paper you can measure hacks
these days in how many libraries of
Congress went out the door and it's not
just government sites where you're being
attacked it's not just classified
information that's being stolen
it's information from companies
information about intellectual property
chemical pharmaceutical formulas biotech
information designs of new aircraft the
design of the f-35 was stolen before the
f-35 ever flew it's corporate
information its corporate information
like what is the new product when is it
coming out how much is it going to cost
it's corporate information like what are
the other oil companies going to bid to
get that big Iraqi oil concession you
may have noticed that two weeks before
the auction on the last Iraqi oil
concession most of the major oil
companies around the world were hacked
except for the Chinese oil company which
won the bid it happens every day
cyber crime happens every day cyber
espionage happens every day
the secret network at the Pentagon has
been hacked the Secretary of Defense's
personal computer has been hacked the
Chancellor of Germany's personal
computer has been hacked the head of the
British security service sent a letter
two years ago to the CEOs of the 300
largest corporations in the UK and it
said you must assume that your network
has been successfully hacked and your
intellectual property has been taken by
the government of China and I suggested
to Janet Napolitano that she perhaps
she'd like to write that letter to a few
people Google you may recall admitted
that it had been hacked by a Chinese
entity and that its source code was
compromised what we now know
is that Google was right when it said in
its press release we're different from
other companies because we're telling
you we were hacked what we now know is
that during that one hacking campaign
3,000 American companies were
successfully hacked so likely head of
the British secret service Security
Service I think we need to say to people
if you have anything of value in the
intellectual property however fleeting
in value if you have formulas designs
anything of value it's been taken it's
already gone this despite the fact that
we spend hundreds of millions of dollars
every year in this country on antivirus
software and on things called firewalls
and intrusion detection systems and
intrusion prevention systems none of
that stuff is successfully stopping
these penetrations that's cyber
espionage what's the difference then
between cyber espionage and cyber war a
few keystrokes because if you have
penetrated a network in order to collect
information you can then take the next
step of engaging in destruction
disruption or damage in cyber war I
think is when a nation-state engages in
unauthorized penetrations of a network
to do disruption destruction or damage
now a lot of people still think about
cyber war in terms of ones and zeroes
attacking each other on some fourth
dimension cyber war is actually
something that happens in the real world
if you don't believe me ask the people
who were running the Iranian centrifuges
seems somebody created a very targeted
cyber guided missile and launched it
against the Iranian centrifuges
it's called Stuxnet by the media yes
tu X any
he involved encryption it involved four
zero day attacks zero day attacks are
very valuable things in cyber war their
attack techniques that have never seen
the light of day before this attack use
not one but four it stole certificates
from various sites so that it looked
authentic it attacked one kind of
software a Siemens issued kind of
software that runs electric systems
Siemens wind PC CC and it did well
something once it got into those
networks I note that the International
Atomic Energy Agency observers say that
the centrifuges at Natanz have been
operating at a very slow rate since
Stuxnet got into the wild
it caused centrifuges to slow down and
miss function malfunction somebody did
that the United States government admits
that it experimentally attacked a
electric power grid in Idaho and
experimentally got into the control
system for the electric power grid and
experimentally got into the control for
a particular generator and caused that
generator to malfunction to the point
where it was about to explode
before the experiment was stopped a
couple of years ago I was watching TV
and there was an ad that came on was a
black screen white words being typed on
it said sometimes a power blackout is
just a power blackout sometimes it's
cyber war who is sponsoring this ad and
then the seal of the United States Air
Force appeared
the United States Air Force has created
a numbered Air Force the 24th Air Force
which has no airplanes and has no
missiles 24th Air Force is to fight in
cyberspace the United States Navy has
created a new fleet you know the fifth
fleet is in the Persian Gulf on the
sixth fleets in the Mediterranean on the
seventh fleet isn't off Japan
well the 10th fleet has now been created
and it has no ships its job is to fight
in cyberspace Leon Panetta tells us in
public testimony that between 20 and 30
nations have created military or
intelligence organizations to fight in
cyberspace so cyber war is real and it
can cause things to happen it can cause
generators to explode
it can cause trains to derail I asked
the head of Union rail if he relied a
lot on computers he said dick I'm not a
train company I'm a computer company
that has trains remember when the red
line derailed last year the metros
response to that was to have the
conductor's start driving the trains
because up until then the computers have
been driving the trains and the
derailment occurred because one of the
computers malfunctioned one of the
little switches on the tracks the cyber
war plans they're being drawn up by many
nations around the world cause attacks
or could cause attacks that would
explode generators that would cause high
tension wires to melt that would derail
trains that would cause gas pipelines to
explode or that could cause mass
confusion in financial systems now so
far the United States government at
least has drawn a red line around
attacking financial systems but a
demonstration of how computer dependent
our financial system is was the other
day or actually a year ago by now when
the stock market well went a little
funny one afternoon and some stocks that
had very little intrinsic value were
trading one company had a net value of a
trillion dollars by the time the hour
was over and other companies that had
obvious value were trading at about a
penny a share something well little
funny and the SE C's answer to that was
oops let's just pretend that our never
happened and we're going to set all the
values back to just before that began
and the investigation that's going on
thinks that the answer was that one of
the many computers engaged in automated
trading made a little trading action
that generated that mistake well what
else could you do to the stock market if
you were malicious so I'm not saying
cyber wars about to happen although
there are little examples of it that are
happening some regularity but
nation-states do not go out and attack
each other just because they have a new
weapon thankfully you get a new sports
car you might go out and break the law
see how fast you can go nations usually
don't do things like that
we've had nine nations with nuclear
weapons and no one's used them in anger
since 1945 but when you do have in the
future political circumstance and
economic circumstance where a
nation-state decides it wants to conduct
wartime activities it has the option now
of conducting wartime activities in
cyberspace a standalone cyber attack or
augmenting kinetic war with cyber war
and as you look out on the horizon and
ask yourself when when might that happen
to the United States what scenario could
develop
think about what would happen if Israel
bomb the Iranian nuclear facilities or
if the United States enforced the last
UN Security Council resolution that
allows for the inspection of Iranian
bound ships on the high seas and somehow
all of that kind of activity generates a
situation where we're dropping iron on
Iran Iran would presumably want to do
something back here in the United States
and in the past for them to attack in
the United States they would have had to
call on his Bala or LaHood's force to do
a terrorist attack but now in the age of
cyberspace an Iranian cyber force could
attack in the United States without ever
leaving tehran isfahan wherever they are
and they could cause the kind of
disruption that I've just spoken about
causing key elements of our
infrastructure to explode and
malfunction and it's as though our
policy is as though we were a football
team that believed you only needed an
offensive squad you know think about the
Redskins if they only had an offensive
squad no not that example I mean the
team with a really good offensive squad
think about the best team in the league
with the best offensive squad but think
about them showing up one day without a
defensive line that's kind of the United
States we've got a really good offensive
capability in cyberspace but we do not
have the ability to defend this country
it is the policy of this government that
the new cyber command defends the
military my friends in the Department of
Homeland Security are supposed to defend
the rest of the government and somehow
the two of them are supposed to
provide advice or something to the rest
of us but essentially the electric power
grids the railroads the banks the
pipelines all of the things that would
be attacked in a war are on their own
and the government's policy when you
boil it down says you guys should really
defend yourselves it's a bit like if in
the 1960s we had said to the president
of US Steel the Russians have a lot of
bombers and in the case of a war they
may come and bomb your steel plants in
Pittsburgh so you US Steel I'll go out
and buy some fighter planes some air
defense missiles to protect yourself
that's what we're saying that's our
policy
all you Electric Power Company companies
and all you chemical companies all you
refineries all you train companies you
ought to do more on cyber security we
might give you some advice that's our
policy and in terms of cyber war
what is our national strategy for
fighting cyber world what are the rules
of cyber war we don't have one as far as
I can tell we don't have a national
strategy and the Pentagon implies that
they have one as far as I can tell they
don't it's akin to the early 1960s in
the arena of strategic nuclear strategy
now when the Kennedy administration came
into office and they asked Curtis LeMay
and others what is our strategic nuclear
strategy they are a bit horrified to
find out with our strategic nuclear
strategy at the time was to go first it
was called launch on strategic warning
means go first and our strategy was to
launch all of our weapons against all of
the targets set in the Soviet Union
China Poland Germany Czechoslovakia
and the Kennedy administration said well
you know I think we need a more refined
strategy than that from what I can tell
our policy on cyber war strategy is very
similar to the Curtis LeMay strategy for
strategic nuclear war we need a strategy
and we needed publicly discussed the way
the Kennedy administration publicly
discussed strategic nuclear strategy we
need congressional review we need
academic participation and we need to
know what the law implications are of
cyber war are they the same as the as
the laws of armed conflict are there
things that are off-limits and how can
you be sure when you launch a cyber war
that it will only hit the target I
talked a little while ago about Stuxnet
which seems to have been targeted on the
tonsils centrifuges but caused an Indian
communications satellite to stop working
so there are issues of collateral damage
and finally let me suggest that when
we're thinking about cyber war we need
to think about cyber arms control and I
know all of you who have done arms
control will immediately say oh there's
a verification problem because many of
you said that about biological arms
control and chemical arms control and
strategic nuclear arms control and
conventional arms control in Europe and
those were hard problems too but those
were hard problems that we got through
it took 15 years to negotiate
conventional arms control in Europe well
we got an agreement just in time for the
Warsaw Pact to collapse but nonetheless
we got an agreement it takes a long time
you begin with baby steps you begin with
confidence-building measures but we're
not doing any of that with regard to
cyber war and it may not be the case
that cyber war is a mean of both arms
control but we'll never know until we
try to find out
and right now the administration is not
seriously trying to find out so with all
that I hope I have adequately prepared
you for the keep fear alive
rally a week from tomorrow thanks very
much
there are some in the military who
probably have very small minority to
think that there actually should be a
fifth service Army Navy Marine Corps Air
Force and cyber how do you feel about
that well I did find in the research for
doing the book that there was a two-star
Air Force general who had said before a
congressional committee you know in the
past we demanded physical fitness
standards of our people but but you know
when I think about what we need now he
said I don't care if the if the person
can run five miles with a pack on their
back as long as they can take down an
electric power grid so that suggests to
me that at least the military's is
beginning to adapt to the to the needs
of cyber war I think it may be a while
before they create their own service sir
mmm with regard to Stuxnet is there is
there anything that can be learned by
the after-effects of Stuxnet in terms of
what the Iranian response is or is not
or what their capabilities are and what
does that tell us about the risks of an
offensive strategy of whether it's ours
Israel's whoever you know does I think
there are lessons to be learned from
Stuxnet the first lesson is that
a very sophisticated complex weapon
could be made and I think it's pretty
obviously has been made by a
nation-state and has been used so when
we were writing the book a lot of this
sounded theoretical when we were looking
for examples of unclassified examples we
didn't have the perfect one that Stuxnet
is and I think Stuxnet makes the case
that nation-states are involved in this
that they are doing very sophisticated
attacks but I think Stuxnet also
demonstrates that there are problems
with collateral damage this was meant to
be a very targeted attack and if you
look at at the code if you decompile the
attack as people have there are all
sorts of things built into the attack so
that it doesn't spread it's almost as
though you know the the codes for the
attack was reviewed by a legal committee
I was supposed to get a reaction
you talked about the challenges inherent
in trying to reach a any kind of treaty
with regard to cyber war and I wonder if
an additional challenge isn't that there
are still significant segments of the
government that think that we can and
must dominate cyberspace and yet it
seems hard to imagine that any other
countries could enter into a treaty that
locks in our supposed dominance of
cyberspace yeah it's it glad you used
the word dominance because as you read
through the unclassified and I suspect
the classified military documents on
cyber war this word dominance keeps
reoccurring what is our objective
dominance of the domain dominance of
cyberspace the Navy renamed their
organization and the Navy headquarters
staff that deals with cyber war the
cyber dominance office I will skip the
obvious joke I think the United States
needs if it's going to enter into
international agreements to mitigate the
damage that can be done by cyber war
yeah to give up some options you know I
think international agreements and
particularly arms control agreements you
got to give you've got to accept limits
on yourself and if our policy is in fact
what the Navy and others keep saying
about dominance then we won't get an
arms control agreement this is why I
think this is an issue for the president
for the National Security Council where
the military can make their case that
they should be unfettered to achieve
dominance if if that were something that
you thought actually could be achieved I
doubt that it can be I think the fact
that we are so weak ourselves and so
unable to defend ourselves really calls
into question the the use of the word
dominance you know if if the United
States has in some attack cyberattack
done something in another country but
they in return have turned out the
lights in Washington and stopped the
natural gas from the pipelines and
derailed our trains
oh no whose dominated whom there how
would you structure and where would you
begin building in defenses for the US
private sector well that's a good
question you know I used to think that
to defend the private sector you had to
defend everything and in fact our when
we had a national strategy back in in
the Clinton administration and early
Bush administration national strategy
for cyber security it pretty much called
for everything to be defended I think
you have to be much more selective
really to get something done and I think
you have to concentrate on a few things
I would concentrate on securing the
power grid on which so much else depends
and I would look at the five or six
internet service providers that are the
the backbone ISPs and I would through
regulation nasty word in Washington I
know through regulation require those
five or six backbone ISPs to filter
what's moving across cyberspace and look
for packets which have known signatures
of attacks that is a doable technology
it could be doing it today some of them
actually are doing it today but they do
not have the benefit of all of the
attacks signatures that the government
has the simple FCC regulation if the FCC
were allowed to regulate the internet
that said the Tier one ISPs have to
reach an agreement with the government
for filtering for malware filtering for
attacks would get us 85% of the way I
think
my question was simply whether or not
your book proposes the elements of a
plan or the general contents of a plan
and if not what you think we should do
yeah it does it has elements of a
defensive strategy and it has elements
of initial steps in arms control the
defensive strategy builds around as I
just said the electric power grid
securing the electric power grid which I
think could be done right now the
federal Electric Regulatory Commission
has issued rules for securing the power
grid but it is incapable of auditing to
know whether those rules are being
implemented and I think doing the the
filtering for attacks on the backbone
that's that's the beginning of a
defensive strategy and we make some
whole series of small suggestions for
the beginning of arms of arms control
beginning with confidence-building
measures about two years ago we had a
session at CSIS which was attended by a
cyber note from the Pentagon someone
from the Goldman Sachs and the Pentagon
gentlemen said that they had been the
the record had been six million attempts
of intrusion in a single day and the
Goldman Sachs fellow said what we've
reached about a million is there any way
of figuring out what percentage might
have been successful out of six million
and 1 million no i-i've seen this ad
that the Air Force ran that begins by
saying you know this building is
attacked six million times a day and
it's the Pentagon well if your
definition of an attack is a king behind
by a computer that's not my definition
of an attack I think they when they use
the the word attack in that context I
think there it loses all meaning and the
the number of attempts I think has
absolutely no correlation with the
number of successes
and grant LexisNexis at my question is
kind of if you have any idea for how
does the law of war potentially move
from conventional war to cyber war with
just kind of fundamental concepts like
imminence to the threat and target
distinction and proportionality I'm not
sure I fully understand how
proportionality fits outside of a
kinetic environment so if I don't have
thoughts on that well you do have to ask
yourself if there is a cyber attack on
you why should you be limited to a cyber
attack in return and if you're not from
a military perspective it seems to me
that you shouldn't be and that you'd
want to be able to respond kinetically
to a cyber attack but once you've done
that I don't know where proportionality
goes it's very hard for me to to make
those those distinctions we do have in a
laws of war that say that we're not
supposed to attack certain kinds of
facilities certainly civilian facilities
in general but specifically hospitals
and others and that's fine if you think
you can control the attack if you take
out the power grid it's going to knock
off the electricity going to hospitals
if you're going to try to not do that I
don't know how you take down the power
grid leave the power grid up but only
the line to the hospital is running I
think there are they're serious
questions about how the treaties we've
already signed have meaning in cyber war
and people are only beginning to think
about that
I just just came from a discussion and
which the legal advise of one of our
allies close allies described their
national security strategy statement and
included in the four areas that they're
concerned about cyber issues and in
outlining five challenges facing in the
national community he mentioned the
growing use of the electromagnetic field
what is is that the same thing or is
that no no there's a whole group of
people who who think there are
electromagnetic weapons out there and
that we need to worry seriously about
those and I I think they somewhat
exaggerated no I I think the the effects
however can be the same which is to wipe
out computer memory and the thing that
we really haven't all internalized yet
particularly people our age haven't
internalized yet is that everything in
our society depends upon computers and
that airplanes now are just a bunch of
software trains everything we do all day
long the electric power of the water we
get everything is dependent upon a
computer-controlled network and even
though people may tell you that these
computer control networks are air gapped
or not connected to the Internet or
inaccessible for attackers anytime any
cyber war unit or even sophisticated
hacker has tried to get in to these air
gap networks they have the Pentagon's
secret network of a sipper net
supposedly air-gapped has been
penetrated according to the Pentagon and
the control systems for the power
distribution grid which they say is
separate from the Internet people have
penetrated by moving from the Internet
to the corporate intranets of the
electric power companies and from there
to the state and network
that run the power grid so the thing we
really have to come to grips with is
that everything that we do all day long
is now dependent upon computer networks
operating and it's not not just cyber
criminals who are taking advantage of
that and it's not just cyber spies who
are taking advantage of that it is
beginning to be militaries and we're
taking advantage of that and the
defense's we have deployed do not work
until this country comes to seriously
understand that we will continue to be
vulnerable
as you know this is Cyber Awareness
Month I think that is definitely doing
his part to make us aware and I think
he's raised a number of issues that will
give us lots of things to think about
again please go to our website WWE
Network forward slash NAT security well
I think we'll this will be up on the web
and also all of our application process
for our annual event our annual
convention but we we don't want you to
go away empty-handed because we know how
much you like attorneys so we're giving
you are the ABA product which is the US
intelligence community lost sourcebook
so if you're having takes their time in
life in which you want to look up the
laws that trouble this will be something
I know that you will cherish for a long
time thank you so much
you